MAINTAININGING HIS FIRST STANLEY
CUP PLAYOFF START. AT
THE SAME TIME.
>> John: MAX DOMR IT.
ALONG WITH ERIK HAUL A, A FORMER
HURRICANE.
BACK TO TH
COMING BACK IS SLAVIN PESTERED
BY!
VINCENT TROCHECK IN THE RIGHT
PLACE AT THE RIGHT TIME!OUTSTAN
RIGHT THERE.
HE USE IT IN.
OPEN ICE ON THE
EXIT OUT OF THE ZONE IS GOING TO
MOVED ALONG.
CUT OFF BY CHARLIE COYLE.
TO THE
Y COYLE.
HE HAS GOT THE GOAL.
TH
PERIOD.
>> JohA STICK OFF
JARVIS HIGH.
CANES SEND IT BACKSTICK.D BURIE
ON A BLOCKERD RETRIEVING
IT AND FORCING CAROLINA TOICE.
LAZAR HAS STICK.
JARVIS AT THE POINT.
EIGHT SECONDS ON THEPESCE.
STOPPED BY SWAYMAN.
HACK AND WHACK TIME OUB OF
FOCUSING THROUGH TRAFFIC.
WATC
CHARLIE COYLE.
PASTRNAK AGAING PLACES WITH BRA
MARCHAND.
HIS SHOT.
PASTRNAK SCORES!: WELL IT WASN'
PERFECTION BUT IT ENDS UP AS A
GOAL.
PASTRNAK WHO HAD PLENTVAINEN DU.
,
LOOKING FOR THEIR FIRST WIN IN!
PASTRNAK.
THEY
GAME ONE.
BIG FOR HIM.
CLIFTON MOVES IT OFF FOR CRAIG
SMITH.
SLAVIN WITH A SHOTE BACK OF THEN
HE RELEASED IT.
SWAYMAN WAVED AT IT AND MISSED .
FAST FORUGH ONE PAST HIM AND
GOOD STOPS HERE LATE..